frozen pizza tore open pizza party
frozen pizza party tour we're going to
different peoples houses to try
different frozen pizzas we're frozen
pizza all right of course it's now in
the frozen food it's next to the liquor
that makes more sense than you think I
[ __ ] used to eat whole tombstone
pizzas not for lunch for an activity all
right so now we're off to crystalline
occurs place to cook the first pizza
it's me my apartment complex I am the
only person under 65 or so so what are
we gonna judge these pizzas on okay so
let's get those rubric down cheese
stretch Chris penis perfect bite press
italiano or Italian yes and
transformation that's great I think
that's really good this makes things
everybody doesn't at the time all right
well let's go cook and eat the first
pizza my grandfather gave me the second
player and he didn't give it to me I
took it once he passed away this is my
heart I notice you got square plates
yeah that's sick hey there we go I think
this looks pretty good this is a classic
transformation it didn't do anything I
didn't expect I can't wait to eat this
you should because it'll burn the [ __ ]
out of your mouth oh I would say two and
a half inches three inches we both feel
pretty good about our perfect bites yeah
are you Lee to country I say this is
Italian you know yeah I think an Italian
would
not think this is great no wow factor
really I think we got to keep touring
these parties on the right oh you gotta
say hashtag no we don't brother beans
are buying George Duke Everdeen so now
we're heading to your friend Brian's
house right I'm looking for the best
free preacher ah I'm gonna put a slice
in and give it a critique and then I'm
gonna go and continue to eat some more
pizza
I'll meet you eat some pizza with keeps
friend he's a barista yeah
Brian wool lives in a pretty shady part
of town I mean there has been a dead guy
in his yard before but we're gonna have
some picked up we have a jack supreme
pizza
of course this looks better than the
last one but this is also because the
candles is because of the pizza platter
I'm trying to not let that affect you
it's also because of the high quality of
Jack's pizza I'm not gonna deal with
this Brian I saw the picture this baby
got cute let's say this oh nice cheese
balls a little cheese cool so there is
some stretch to this cheese I don't see
them any perfect bikes laying around
it's got a good crunch but this has zero
crust no wow factor over here I hate to
break your guys's heart you love it it's
a pizza that makes you feel good even if
it's a medium pizza yeah that's the
homeless guy we gave the first chicken
to really yeah on average each person in
the United States eats around 23 pounds
of pizza every year it's person just
like two babies worth a pizza we're
almost to my house we're gonna see my
girlfriend and try a tombstone pizza so
this is tombstone what are more
importantly this is Keith's girlfriend
Becky who's my girlfriend Becky it
really transformed for me what is that
look okay okay
it's good stretch thank you grab some
hot grease on my arms so grab a piece
that you think has a good perfect bite
on it look there's some sausage under
that pepper
oh wow the littlest bit of crispness to
the bottom of the pizza I don't know the
crest is a little garnish italiano
it was really good looking frozen really
good looking cooked and it tastes really
good
I agree I'm also gonna give this a WOW
factor mm-hmm lucky Wow there it is I
feel like it's to get the sexy nod over
the wow factor
no I think well maybe I mean they're
diehard fans who know the difference
between a WOW factor and it's sexy
all right I'm not throwing it around
kind of I wasn't throwing it around what
are you doing I wasn't sure what a sexy
was and I wouldn't be this bad a
sexiness how about them you don't know
what it is if you're not seeing the
other two videos thank you have you not
seen the other ticket yes I saw the
beginning you can say it if you want
frozen pizza party torte to Kate did you
even care that we're here right now it
is for the pizza fact Mike
the first known pizzeria antica pizzeria
opened in Naples Italy in 1738 what's
crazy is that there was a world without
pizza Jesus didn't have pizza why didn't
Jesus invent pizza maybe God was like
the people aren't ready for it yeah so
we're here Brittany's we're going in
we're gonna have some sort of Pete's
that we haven't decided yet ah so
Brittany has chosen wild Mike's do you
don't feel the heat coming out no it
smells like it's just leaking gas
parties are do they work well I think
it's looking pretty good
[Music]
I think that was a five inch Easter
that was a 10 inch cheese stretch were
you there what do you think about the
transformation I mean you know it looks
really good
yeah I didn't taste the price even
though they're not all these bites are
pretty perfect the crust it's got that
buttery flakiness it's really delicious
just gets the wow factor for me I'm
blown away because I had no idea that
wild Mike's existed it's a towel yes she
did a literal nod frozen pizza party
2:15 and now we're on our way to Chris's
improv show at The Improv space we have
a nice day and Lindsey with us who met
we met on Twitter you seem a little
flustered from flustered I feel like I'm
not doing this pizza justice it looks
awful and it's all my fault we can be
honest it's under there join us next we
got to figure out where exactly we're
gonna eat the dish I'm gonna pick up
some rocks and just find a party
yeah let's close it
[Applause]
it's pretty hot but it's also stretchy
cheese I think I think the
transformation is pretty yes it's pretty
what do you think about the sex appeal
of this pizza as the crust Rises it just
makes you want to eat it yeah make
something else rising alright if the
crust is by far the most outstanding a
little dry this looks like a pizza full
of perfect bites hots damn good that has
the wow factor for me yeah you know I
might give this yarn on my 69 overall
this is a really solid pizza today has
been a real achievement and there's only
one thing left to do
[Music]
Oh music sing yes the type of losing
[ __ ] lose your hand
lose control lose your heart lose your
soul Pachelbel packed away lots of
pizzas priceless life count each one
delicious